another day though of some long wait
times at the las vegas convention center
as people
arrive to try to get their second dose
of the vaccine yeah some real winding
lines organizers at the site had to cut
off the line a bit early today
madison kimbrough joins us there live
last time we checked in with you madison
the line was done but earlier today it
was brutal
yes definitely brutal people were in
line around the building
and to tell you the truth with the 11
o'clock and round eleven this morning
that's when the cut-off happened and
people just stopped
being in line so take a look at the
footage that we shot where you can
really see the extent of everything
going on today
that caused a lot of frustration for
those who had booked appointments
second dose appointments are now being
added to the cashman center that's
according to the health district
that will start on february 16th now as
of now
walk-in appointments will no longer be
available at the convention center
like before the health district citing
that the convention center has now
reached its pre-registered appointment
capacity unfortunately for now people
were walking in and out of the building
with ease
today understanding the circumstances at
hand
it was a pretty good experience it took
two and a half hours but it was okay you
know it was
shorter than i thought it would be i
mean they have a ton of paramedics in
there
they're putting in a lot of overtime
shifts they're they're double shifting i
mean
there's only so many people that are
qualified to give shots
this location opened to watkins last
week for those who had their first dose
of the moderna vaccine
but could not schedule an appointment
for the second dose online
so this week it was announced that
walk-ins were available
for the pfizer vaccine too but currently
only people with appointments will be
able to get vaccinated at the convention
center as of now
and if you have an appointment and you
have to for some reason miss it it's
important that you
cancel a lot of these people that are
are not canceling these
appointments are causing a backup and
that's why these long lines are
happening so if you can't make your
appointment
make sure to cancel in advance reporting
live from the las vegas convention
center madison kimbrough 8 news now